So speaking of egalitarian last time we
talked four years ago it was just after
you stepped down from your role as the
benevolent dictator for Life pdfo uh
looking back what are your insights and
lessons
you learn from that experience about
python developer Community about human
nature about human civilization
life itself oh my uh
I probably held on to the position too
long
I remember being just
extremely stressed for a long time
and it wasn't very clear to me
what was leading what was causing the
stress
and looking back
uh
I I should have sort of
relinquished my central role as bdfl
sooner
what were the pros and cons of the bdfl
role like what were the you not
relinquishing it what what are the
benefits of that for the community and
what are the drawbacks well the the
benefits for the community would be
things like
uh
Clarity of vision and sort of
a clear Direction because I I had
certain ideas in in mind when I created
Python and well I sort of let myself be
influenced by many other ideas as python
evolved and became
more successful and more complex and
more used
I also stuck to certain principles and
it's still hard to say what are Python's
core principles
but the fact that I was playing that
role and sort of always very active
grew the community in a certain way
it modeled to the community how to think
about
how to how to solve a certain problem
well
that was a source of stress but it was
also beneficial it was a source of
stress for me personally but it was
beneficial for the community because uh
people people sort of
over time had
learned how I was thinking and could
predict
yeah but how how I would would decide
about a particular issue and not always
perfectly of course but there was like
there wasn't a lot of jerking around
like this year we're all this year the
Democrats are in power and we're doing
these kind of things and now the
Republicans are in power and they roll
all that back and do those kind of
things
there is a clear
fairly straight path ahead
and so fortunately the the successor
structure with the steering Council
has has sort of found a similar way of
of leading the community
in a fairly steady Direction without
stagnating and and for me personally
it's more fun because there are there
are things I can just ignore
yeah oh yeah there's a bug in
multi-processing let someone else decide
whether that's important to solve or not
I'll I'll stick to typing in the async
io and uh the faster interpreter yeah it
allows you to focus a little bit more
yeah